don't start way out there
hey
[Music]
i'm starting way out there
so
oh
okay first thing don't start a million
miles away
let's go back he's gonna
come in showman okay
so he's gonna go
this is not striking the range
you're in close perfect when someone
would decide to hit you
wow okay
so second thing strike goes up that's
the yin opening
up down not the technique
so up i find it but you'll feel the
pressure because he's supposed to strike
down
he does not wait at the top for me
to do my technique
his strike goes up and down
so when i feel the pressure change
that's when i'm getting caught out of
the way
that far away ah i'll feel i'll feel the
weight and i yield to it
underneath the elbow
up down
oh i'm not shoving it down
i'm blending with this down
hold down
up down
third hand positioning just like
[Music]
yo here on your elbow
you can't reach the hat the only way you
can reach the hand
is if you caught it coming down that's a
young young clash
or he was never going to come up
to come down in the first way he's just
sticking his hand out there
in some masturbatory semblance of the
strike
so instead here
baby i feel pressure yield to the
pressure
off yield to the pressure
so he goes up down to the pressure
oh
all right so usually you're okay waiting
there for you
and then you come around and you make
them come over here
wait that's not the strike
so he's going up and then his strike
just goes down
you cannot make that strike it's going
down he's going down
come all the way over here without
pulling him in a young young clash
so it's up in our blend with the
strength
and that is generally all you can get
at full speed and probably less than
this
so rewind the film
this amount of degrees is going to be
somewhere
here and about that
you start looking for more than that and
you're not doing it you're faking
that's it so toward that
end same thing we're going to work out
something my tan con
is going to measure
this relationship i don't tank on where
i want
and bring him around that's a pull
the adhesion on his arm
is what i am measuring where i can con
and how whether it's knee up
knee down all the way not all the way
this check here whoo that determines
where i attend con
[Music]
off
they don't go way behind him your
dragons
up hey
just like me this is a reaction drill so
when i push down he wants to come up
i have to feel that okay so he's not
sitting here
and then i take his wrist if he's if
he's just gonna sit there and then just
take the gear
when you push he pulls and that's when
you go to the technique
so boom boom that's what i want to feel
then in the same way your tencon
is being governed by this ik adhesion
it depends that's going to determine
where you step
how you step so the same thing here as
he goes
up i'm looking for that back outward
kazushi
and tightness so i don't want all this
slack in his arm
and then he rolls himself so maybe i go
into the elbow
maybe the wrist maybe smaller
but there can't be slack in this arm
it's the feeling feeling oh
don't have one way
feeling
and be cognizant of that other arm
if you have slack here you're going to
get it
so feeling and placement
so
oh
this arm here is not out by my hands
my body goes right to it
here right to it so i have the trap here
i don't want space
right to it his tricep right to my body
oh right here so sometimes i have to
step to do it
sometimes i don't when i get right my
body on it
this just starts to drop boom
right here right here body on it
i drop
drop
[Music]
you'll want to walk around
that opening is not going to be there go
up
focusing on the ending
so right when i bring my body to it
to the tricep his
tricep area and elbow is going to be on
the front side of my spine
so when i drop my weight
it's on the front side not the back side
front side here is where i end up
so my body
and not my arm is doing the pin
so you straighten your arm you're not
gonna get it
body here my body does it
not my arm i'm not doing this stuff
bonnie so i have to set that
up same side okay i have to set that
up already here i'm setting that up
and it's on not here
going like that
set it up drop
front side body not
back side of my spine foot side
no not going to be strong enough resist
not going to get it body here
then let's go